Let's look at the Twinmotion UI and learn to navigate in the viewport.
To that purpose, we'll use the 01-context project file that has been provided to you.
It's essentially the same setup that was used in the last video,
except that the data has been imported as a Datasmith file instead of using a direct link.
Normally, when you start Twinmotion, you are greeted with a Home page,
which you can also access at any time using the Home icon.
This page offers you some news, quick access to recent projects,
a Learning tab to get up to speed on Twinmotion,
and a Templates page to help you start a project based on your line of work.
These templates are downloadable so you can download only those that you need.
The Home page automatically shows a startup unless you disable that option.
Close the Home page.
Let's look at viewport navigation and then move on to explore the various UI components.
For the most part, Twinmotion uses the same navigation tools that you have in Unreal Engine,
and by default, a navigation panel is displayed at the top of the viewport to remind you of those hotkeys.
For example, you can use the right mouse click to look around,
the AWSD keys to walk around,
Furthermore, you can alter the camera speed by using the 1-6 keys, going from slower to faster movement.
The mouse wheel on its own is used for panning or to orbit around when used with the Shift key.
You can do some minimal adjustments using the Settings icon to set the hotkeys to mimic your DCC app.
For example, setting the hotkeys to 3ds Max forces the orbit to use Alt and mouse wheel instead of Shift.
I personally like to set the key mapping to Unreal Engine mode for consistency as I use both products.
Once you are comfortable with the settings you have chosen, you can hide the navigation panel altogether.
If you need to recall it, you can do so from the Eye menu which gives you faster access to common tools
such as Time of Day or Camera Speed if you forget about the hotkeys.
Another simple UI component is the Maximize-Minimize Viewport toggle that does exactly as the name implies.
Other than these two viewport icons we just discussed, there are four more areas that make the Twinmotion interface.
There's a toolbar that gives you access to transform tools, move, rotate, scale, as well as a material picker to sample the materials off objects.
There is also a button to activate Path Tracing render mode if your hardware permits it.
The toolbar can be expanded to give you access to further functionality like local transforms and pivot point adjustments.
Two more UI elements are rather prominent, the asset library to the left and the scene graph to the right.
The asset library as the name implies contains a plethora of ready-made assets that you can add to the scene using a simple drag and drop.
You can easily navigate through the various asset categories and sub-categories or search by keywords.
The scene graph on the other hand displays the asset data and hierarchies in your scene.
You can use it to select scene objects and control their visibility.
The Ambience section of the scene graph is important.
It doesn't relate to an asset in the scene but rather to the environment as a whole.
It lets you adjust global lighting parameters based on the time of day.
It lets you adjust exposure with full manual control if you need it.
You can set the weather and seasons to your liking.
You can adjust the North direction, date and location anywhere in the world.
You can use a custom background including an HDRI panorama or a simple background which we'll experiment with later.
You can even enable an ocean effect if you are simulating certain areas of the world.
The right side of the screen is in fact made of different panels that you can toggle on or off.
The Scene Graph and Properties panel are rather prominent, but you also have access to a Transforms panel.
This panel will give you better control over the placement of objects in the scene.
There is also a View Sets panel which we'll not be discussing in this class.
At the bottom of your screen is the Dock.
A series of five panels that you use to control various aspects of the scene.
You already know a bit about the Import panel.
The Materials panel shows you the materials used in the scene, including the imported ones.
The Populate option opens a panel on the right that gives you access to more creation techniques.
This is where you access the Foliage tool to scatter vegetation.
It also gives you access to animation tools based on path motions.
Again, you will experiment with these shortly.
But you also have access to an Urban tool which lets you add context to your project.
By adding surroundings.
This Urban tool will be the main topic that we'll investigate next, but let's keep moving on with the UI.
The last two panels in the Dock are about outputting data.
The Media panel is where you define still images, videos or panoramas that you plan to produce.
Once you set them up in a satisfactory way, you use the last panel, the Export panel, to output them to disk.
The project was imported nicely into Twinmotion, but it looks a little bare.
In the next step, you add context to the Community Center in the form of surrounding buildings.